E
YOU AT OUR PAST. RAID THAT IS.
BUT THAT'S- THE CLIMB. AND THAT
ARTS FOR. GREAT IN FLORIDA IS
ONE OF THE LOWEST ANYWHERE I'M
IN THE COUNTRY. STATE OF THE
SIZE ABOUT ONE POINT 3% AND I
THINK PART OF THE SAME ARE YOU
HAPPY THAT- WELL I THINK
THERE'S TWO MAIN REASONS ONE IS
FLORES LASER FOCUSED ON
PROTECTING THE MOST VULNERABLE
PARTICULARLY. SENIORS IN LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES BUT ALL
LIKE A BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE'VE
GOT A GREAT MEDICAL HERE STATE.
OF SOUTH FLORIDA. OUR AT LEAST
BECAUSE THE PHYSICAL WANTED TO
MORE THAN RING APPEAR YEAH
MINISTRY RESPONSE VERY AND WE
HAD MOST SHIP OF THEIR DOESN'T
TO HOUSE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF TRANSPOSITIONS ARE USING
THAT- AND THEY ARE. BETTER
PATIENT OUT. NOW YEAH. IN MARCH
AND APRIL THE- TOP PART OF THAT
IS JUST NOT OF THAT IS I THINK
OUR IF PASSED. HARD PEOPLE WORK
HERE SO EVEN AS WE'VE SEEN YEAH.
CENSUS COVID STABLE DECLINED IN
MANY PARTS OF THE STATE WE
RECOGNIZE THE GREAT WORK THAT
CERTAIN PEOPLE BEEN DOING
PARTICULARLY HERE IN MIAMI DADE
COUNTY. I WILL STOP MOST.
MISSIONS ANYWHERE IN THE STATE
BUT YOU KNOW THE SYSTEM HAS
WORKED- YEAH THERE'S STILL
CAPACITY HOPEFULLY WE'RE NOT
GONNA NEED MORE WITH. THE PAGE
IN THE NEXT COMING. I'M. STATE.
THAT'S JUST THE SYSTEM AND PUT
IN HER MORE VALVES THROUGHOUT
SOUTH FIVE SO WE'RE HERE TO
HELP WITH ANYTHING YOU DO TO IS
RELEASED THE I THINK THIS YOU
KNOW COMES ON THE HEELS OF SO
MUCH TO KEEP THAT IN FLORIDA
BUT NOW WITH THESE TRIALS ARE
WERE REALLY REALLY- LOOKING
FORWARD TO WHAT THE UNIVERSITY
OF MIAMI CAN TRIBUTE AT TODAY'S
SUBJECT VERY IMPORTANT THANK.
PRESIDENT THANK YOU. YOU'VE
GIVEN THE OF PASS FOR THE PRESS
ALL THE SECRETARY ANYTIME WE'VE
CALLED- YOU ALL THAT HAVE
SPRUNG INTO ACTION AND- PEOPLE
FOR ENTERTAINMENT BUT I'M- I.
HAPPY TO BE ABLE HEAR WHAT YOU
GET AGAIN. THANK YOU GOVERNOR
SENATE IN THE I KNOW I OF THE A
PRESS. EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION
FOR YOU. AND TO THE KIND OF
GOVERNMENT JULY SENIOR IN A
STRETCH. WITH A STRONG INSTEAD
LEADER THE YOU. FOR THE PEOPLE
FOR. PREVENT FOUR WE ALSO. OVER
THE DAYS TO REFORM. IS RECENTLY.
ON THAT GOVERNOR. I SAID IT
HELLO MY VISITS. AND THEN COME
PASSED SAY TO GIVE. THE PEOPLE
OF FLORIDA WILL. MAKE SURE THAT
THE STATE OF HAS THE TEST REESE.
PERSON PROTECTIVE FOR SHORT
HEALTH WORKERS AND ALSO THAT
LEADING ROLE IN HELPING US TO
CREATE THE THERAPEUTICS AND THE
NEW VACCINES. IN THE SUNDAY
WILL GET THIS. IN PASS. WE ARE
ENCOURAGED BY THE TABLE TRENDS
HERE IN FLORIDA JUST LIKE YOU
ARE I WANT PEOPLE TO STAY FOR
KNOW THAT WOMEN COULD THERE
SHOULD RESOURCES ARE THERE THE-
TWO. TWO H. THE- ANY IN FLORIDA
BY THE GLOBAL WILL HAVE THE
SAME LEVEL OF CARE. THAT ANY OF
US WE ONE FAMILY MEMBER WALLIS.
TO HELP A GOOD GOVERNOR THANK
YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU FOR. THE
PARTNERSHIP THAT YOU FOR WHICH-
NOT JUST WITH OUR PRESIDENT
MARK TRANSFERS WITH OUR CURRENT
MINISTRATION I AM PLEASED
BECAUSE- THEY'VE. THE FDA. THE
FDA'S CLEARED THE WAY TODAY FOR
WILL US THE FIRST PHASE
CLINICAL IN THE END I STATES
EIGHTY NINE SIDE ACROSS AMERICA.
THIRTY THOUSAND FOR JUST WILL
BEGIN THE FIRST PHASE THREE
CLINICAL TRIAL ON A VACCINE FOR
THE CORONAVIRUS AND LET ME JUST
SAY YOU HAVE. REALLY GREAT. FOR
DOCTOR HANS AT THE F. B. IT IS
REMARKABLE FOR THAT THE JOURNAL
THAT WILL BE OF. FINISHING THIS
PHASE THREE TRIAL ACT ENTERED
ONE BACK IN. MEMBER SERVICES OF
WE MOVED TO THE FIRST. FIRST
THINGS FIRST FOR THE WORK TIME.
WAS LITERALLY JUST A MATTER OF-
OF WEEKS AFTER WE RECEIVE THE
GENETIC CODE FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS. BECAUSE OF THE
STRONG WORK WITH THE FDA AND
URGENCY THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
PLACED ON THIS THE- BEGINNING
OF THE AISLE ACTUALLY. I'M NOT
WE CONTINUE TO AT THE PRESS
CALLED WARP. SPEED SAFELY
POSSIBLE HAVE NO FOR THE
AMERICAN FEED. I WOULD SAY
SUPPORT CONGRESS AS WELL
REPRESENTED HERE BY FRIEND MANY.
CONGRESSMAN MARIO D. AZ LARGE.
WE WERE ABLE TO SECURE. FOR A
VERY FOR IN FIELD DOLLARS
BILLIONS OF WHICH HAVE ALREADY
BEEN DEPLOYED THE COMPANY'S
SUCH AS YOU KNOW GOVERNOR WE'RE
WE'RE NOT WAITING TO CREATE
THEM ACTUALLY IT WAS. FINALLY
APPROVED WITH BOTH MATERNAL
FIZER ANOTHER COMPANY'S WE'RE-
WE'RE ACTUALLY HAVING THEM
CREATE THAT ACTUALLY NOW. AND
THEN TO HAVE IT READY AT THE
POINT AT WHICH WE ACHIEVE THE
FINAL APPROVAL FROM THE FDA
THAT ANY VACCINE. WOULD BE SAFE
TO THE FLOOR. GOLDWYN
MANUFACTURE HUNDRED OF NEW. OF
DOSES. THIS THE HEAVENS WILL
BUY NEXT YEAR IN FACT WE'RE ALL
IN THE- OF PROCURING OVER A
BILLION NEEDLES AND SYRINGES TO
BE ABLE TO DEPLOY PASS TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. PRESIDENT
CALLED OPERATION MORE SPEED AND
THAT'S THAT'S THE SPEED AT
WHICH REMOVED. DEVELOP A
VACCINE THE V. TODAY TO BE HERE
SENATE EIGHT AT A GREAT YEAH.
OF THE DISPLAY. SUCH AN ROLE.
FOR TWO. IN THE MIDST OF THIS
PANDEMIC AND BE FOR OUR TO
THANK YOU. AND FOR THE WAY
UNIVERSITY OF MY- MILLER SCHOOL.
FIVE STEP FORWARD YOU ACTUALLY
CREATED A SEPARATE COVID
HOSPITAL HERE. AT THE CORE OF
THE PATIENTS AND I'VE I WANT TO
AGREE STRONGLY WITH. WITH
GOVERNOR TO SAINT LUKE'S MENTAL.
LEVEL OF CARE. RIGHT HERE IN MY-
UNIVERSITY MIAMI CALLED FLORIDA.
THAT'S HAD THE HEAD THE EFFECT
OF LOWER THE NO PART LOSSES
THAT. HAVE OCCURRED IN SO I ONE
THING YOU FOR THAT. BUT I ALSO
WANTED TO SAY WE HAVE A WE
THOUGHT THERE WOULD BE NO
BETTER PLACE AMONG THE NINE
STATES. ACROSS AMERICA THAT.
MEMBERS YOU MIGHT WHERE IS JUST
A FEW SHORT DAYS THE PHASE
THREE TRIAL OF THE CREW ARE
VACCINE WILL BE AND I HOPE- I
HOPE YOU TAKE IT AND THE WHOLE
TEAM HERE JAMES IS A GREAT
COMPLIMENT. IN A GREAT
STATEMENT OF CONFIDENCE. IN THE
PROFESSIONALISM OF ALL THE
GREAT THIRTEEN HERE THE
UNIVERSITY WILL HAVE OUR. IS
ALSO AND THANK YOU. FOR THE
CORPORATE HAS THAT'S BROUGHT US
REALLY TO THIS OF. ON THIS
HISTORIC DAY. THEY WHEN WE GET.
US IN FACE. OF THE PAST TOWARD
SECURING THE VACCINE FOR THE
PEOPLE SO ONE ME JUST LITTLE
BIT CLOSER AFTER OVER TO THE ON
WILL EXTEND THIS THE PROCESS
WERE WE GOT HERE WHAT WILL BE.
THEY AHEAD OF. THAT'S SIMPLY TO
SAY YOU TO YOU THE NUMBER OF
SYRIAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
URGENCY PUBLIC SPHERE THAT THE
COMPANY HAS BROUGHT TO THIS
EFFORT IS SO MANY OTHER
COMPANIES HAVE TO DEVELOPING A
VACCINES AND THERAPEUTICS SEVEN
THANKS- CONGRESSMAN THAT IS FAR
FROM BERKELEY MEMBERS IN BOTH
POLITICAL PARTIES SHOULD MAKE
THE RESOURCES AND- FOR US TO BE
THIS MOMENT- AND- ONE OF I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO TWO OTHER
FOLKS. TWO STATING YOU PROVIDE.
FOR THE PEOPLE OF STATE OF FOR
AND YOU AND YOUR WHOLE HAS BEEN
THE THAT BUT THERE FOR THE
PEOPLE OF THIS ONCE BECAUSE YOU
FOR YOUR EFFORTS. TO COME
ALONGSIDE PEOPLE IN IN LONG
TERM AND NURSING. IT WAS IN
FLORIDA THAT WE ON EARLY AFTER
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
TESTING THAT WE HAVE THE
SUPPLIES. AND TO SEEK YOUR
SENIORS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THOSE EARLY EFFORTS THEY
WERE TRULY A AN EXAMPLE FOR THE
NATION- CAN WE GO FREE DOES
SAVE LIVES AND WILL CONTINUE TO.
THE SIMPLE ONE SAYING I WANT
SAY THANK YOU TO ALL THE
AMERICANS HAVE LONG. DESPITE IN
THIS PHASE THREE. CLINICAL ALL
THE SEVERAL PLAY. WASH YOUR
HAIR PRACTICE PERSONAL HYGIENE.
WHERE A MASS RETURN THAT IT'S A-
SOURCE THIS IS NOT. BUT THE
THIS WAS HERE TODAY SO THOUSAND
AMERICANS AND STEP FORWARD ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHICH IS
VERY. ACTUALLY TRY AND WE ALSO
HAVE CLINICAL TRIALS THAT ARE.
TAKING PLACE IN THERAPEUTICS
AND OTHER VACCINES AND SO EACH
AND EVERY AMERICAN WHO HAS
VOLUNTEERED TO PARTICIPATE. IN
THESE AND OTHER TRIALS. ON THE
OTHER PRESIDENT ON BEHALF OF A
GRATEFUL NATION WE SAY THANK
YOU BUT LET ME URGE- ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO PARTICIPATE.
IN THIS CLINICAL TRIAL HEARING
MY YOUR ANYWHERE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY YOU CAN GO TO CLINIC I
ALSO. DONE BOTH THAT'S WHEN I
WAS DONE GOOD INVITE AWAY THAT
YOU CAN. DO MORE THAN YOUR PART
TO HELP US REACH THE DATA PUT
THE CALL. IN THE PAST SO THAT
ALL OF IT OVER DR STEPHEN
HANUKKAH'S. OF THE- IN A VERY
NATIONAL. TO WORKING. WITH ALL
THE GREAT HEALTH CARE. AND
THANK YOU FOR IT WOULD BE A FOR
US. THAT WAS. THANK YOU GUYS
THE SENATE AND FOR. REACHING
UPCOMING. MEDICAL HERE WHO ARE
THE FRONTLINE TO COMPARE
PATIENTS MUCH. AND THANK YOU
FOR WHAT YOU DO HOW US GET A
VACCINE BETWEEN THEIR COMPUTER
ANYTHING CLOSER THE WORLD. I'M
GONNA SECOND ONE SEVEN
PRESIDENT TURN OF THE HEROES
ARE FOLKS WHO A LONG. TO BE.
PARTICIPANTS IN THE TRIAL AND
THEY WHAT US TO THE POINT WHERE
THEY CAN AVAILABLE. ASSESS THE-
STATE ABOUT THE- IT SAID SHE
SIGN OF A GREAT AMERICAN
BIOMEDICAL RESEARCH INTO THAT
COULD FOR. THIS TIME. AFTER THE
BECAUSE NINETEEN. THAT WE'VE
BEEN. SO AGAIN JUST TO RIFIC
WORK I THINK FIVE AMERICA
STRESSORS RIGHT WE ALL HAVE THE
TO PLAY. IN THE SENATE AND MORE
THAN YOUR SHARE THAT'S FOR SURE.
YEAH WE ARE DOING ALL WE CAN
JUSTICE OF BACKED. YEAH ENGINE
NO. WE HAD A GONE. TO THE DATE
THAT WILL TO SAY BECAUSE WE-
GREAT SIDE. OUT FOR. NURSES ARE
THERE HE ATE TO WILL BE LOOKING
AT THE DAY WHEN THERE THEY'LL-
FOR THE- FOR. TO TERMINATE SAFE
AND EFFECTIVE. I THINK IT'S
REALLY. SOME OF THE CAN OF THAT
ONE IS FROM SPECIFIED. HOW MANY
PEOPLE SHOULD IMAGE. THIS PRESS
THAT NO PARTICIPANT FROM WALKS
LIFE FOR ALL THE AROUND
PARTICULAR THOSE WHO OFTEN
JINPING UNDERGRAD. A IN
CLINICAL TRIALS DISSIPATE IN
THIS TRIAL SO HAVE THE SAME. OF
THESE ARE RESULTS BEING JAMMED.
ONE THIRTY A SCIENTIST OUR
SENSE FOR BIO VALUATION WILL
NOT CUT FOR. IN THE THAT WILL
NOT CUT CORNERS IN ORDER TO
EVALUATE VACCINE. IN ALTHOUGH
WE HAVE GONE AT SIGNIFICANT
SPEED TO GET TO THIS POINT OUR
JOB AT THE A AND R. SONG COMES
FROM THEIR COMPUTER. IS THAT WE
WOULD JUDGE BASED ON THE- ON
THE GOLD STANDARD WE HAPPEN TO
HAVE K. BURYING THE SAFETY AND
AFTER. OF ATTACKS. THE FDA
SCIENTISTS CALLED BALLS AND
STRIKES THEY DO THIS DAY FOR
THE NEW FOR YOU. HI THERE WHERE
THE INFORMATION THAT WE NEED
AND THEN THE GREAT THAT.
UNIVERSE OF MIAMI DONALD
COUNTRY BE PROVIDING THIS TO
THE FDA. FINALLY WE HAVE A
REALLY. PIPELINE IF. AND IN THE
UNITED STATES AND AROUND THE
WORLD. FOR FORTUNE AND I THINK
GOVERNMENT IS SAYING SOMETHING
FOR TO MENTION THE FACT THAT
WE'RE NOT. FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT PLACE THAN WE HAVE
BEEN HERE. FOR THE LAST COUPLE
OF MONTHS WITH RESPECT TO
THERAPEUTICS BUT ALSO THE GREAT
CARE BEING PROVIDED. AND THERE
ARE MORE HUNDRED VACCINES THAT
ARE BEING LOOKED AT AROUND THE
WORLD IN VARIOUS STAGES OF
DEVELOPMENT. SO WE ARE HAVING
NUMBER THAT IN HOUSE IF YOU. WE
EXPECT AT LEAST EDITION TO BE
FACE TO TRY. IN THE NEXT WEEKS.
SO IT'S TERRIFIC TO BE HERE- I
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT FDA'S ONLY
JOB ON AND WE WILL MAKE. THE
APPROPRIATE COMMUNICATION WITH
RESPECT TO SAY CALIF. THANK YOU
FOR. A PRESS. THANK YOU ALL.
NO